[Música]
recordó a las víctimas del holocausto
encendió una vela en babillar en las
afueras de kiev donde los nazis
ejecutaron a más de 33.500 judíos en
1941 también llamó a combatir la
indiferencia y el odio haciendo
referencia a la guerra en su propio país
La indiferencia y el odio son siempre
capaces de crear el mal Solo Juntos por
eso es tan importante que todos los que
valoran la vida muestran determinación
cuando se trata de salvar a quienes el
odio pretende destruir
flashmir Putin aprovechó la fecha para
reiterar sus argumentos señalando
nuevamente a las autoridades ucranianas
desierneos y de cometer crímenes contra
civiles uno de los motivos con los que
justificó su intervención en Ucrania el
olvido de las lecciones de la historia
conduce la repetición de Terribles
tragedias prueba de ellos son los
crímenes contra civiles las limpiezas
étnicas y las acciones punitivas
cometidos por neonazis en Ucrania contra
ese mal luchan ahora valerosamente
hombro con hombro nuestros soldados a la
guerra de palabras se contrapone la del
terreno según el embajador ucraniano en
Francia distintos países han prometido
el envío de 321 tanques de guerra
Incluyendo los deseados leopardos de
Alemania y los 31 abrahams
estadounidenses Polonia anunció este
viernes que mandará a otros 60 tanques
además de los 14 leoparda alemanes que
ya había prometido Canadá llegó que
enviará cuatro de ellos en el frente el
presidente ucraniano describe la
situación como extremadamente aguda
particularmente en donetsky ahora que
presiona para recibir aviones de combate
f-16 pero sus socios occidentales se
niegan en hacerlo argumentando que
llevaría la guerra a un nuevo nivel